welcome to the podcast guests hey thanks
thank you so much so today we have David
liebe he is a product director at Google
specifically for Google photos what some
people might not know is you are also a
co-founder of bump and bump was one of
the biggest apps on the App Store for
the first years the iPhone how did that
happen
yeah totally random so we I was in
business school I had been an engineer
and I kind of went to the dark side and
went to business school in the fall of
2008 this was right when the iPhone had
come out a year earlier they just opened
up the App Store to third-party
developers that summer so I showed up to
business school and I like met a couple
people in the computer science
department who had built like apps over
the summer and this one guy I met he had
built an app that looked for open Wi-Fi
networks and it just like told you which
ones were open and which ones had a had
like a pay or whatever it's called a
password and he made two hundred
thousand dollars that summer selling
that I was like okay we should we should
build an app here and at the same time I
was in Business School and I was meeting
all my new business school classmates
and we were doing that thing that like
we still honestly do today which was hey
tell me your phone number I'll type it
in then I'll call your phone you just
missed the call and then you ask me how
to spell my name like one day I did that
ten times and I was like okay somebody
should solve this and oh there's apps
now I could probably solve it so I
emailed a guy I met I didn't really even
work with him directly but I had met at
my previous job at Texas Instruments and
I said handy like any interest in
building an iPhone app and at the time
he was like I think androids gonna be
bigger and I said let's start with
iPhone I think it'll be better and so we
just started hacking away and trying to
build this app to make it easier to
share your phone number with people that
you met it was a total side project I
was like a full-time business school
student he was doing his own thing he
was in California we just kind of worked
on it for a while we met I met my third
co-founder Jake Mintz at business school
he was also just a random classmate of
mine we met we both had worked at Texas
Instruments so we like started to talk
about that and we brought him on board
and the three of us just kind of did the
whole thing ourselves in our spare time
and we put it on to the App Store and
people started using it and we were like
oh and this was in 2008 to the night we
launched March 27th 2009 was one
got out to the kite and at the time is
very non obvious that apps are gonna be
big I remember watching the after first
like fart apps yeah you know like silly
trivial things and I think a lot of
people viewed bump as a silly trivial
thing to write it was like this kind of
novelty of the iPhone like oh yeah it's
got an accelerometer you can bump your
phones together and it does something
but that actually was like the engine
that made it grow so like we launched it
in March we got a few people started
using it was growing slowly but then
because of that like novelty and the
fact that the iPhone was a thing in the
news around that time every reporter
wanted to talk about the coolest apps on
the iPhone and so I remember I met one
reporter from the Chicago Tribune at
like a random business school conference
yes and I emailed him and I'm like hey
I've got this cool app you might want to
write about it and you wrote about it
and then I did this little hack where I
took his article and I forwarded it to
like the next highest person on the like
journalism Reich and I think I mailed it
to David Pogue at the New York Times I
was like hey the Chicago Tribune 'he's
got this already but you could still
write about it and then he wrote about
it and then I took that and I like went
up the notch and eventually it just got
pretty popular and I think we were we
were like that maybe on the like 200 on
the top app chart at the time that the
billionth app was going to be downloaded
from the App Store okay and because we
we were the top 200 app we were getting
a lot of downloads that day so the
probability of us being the billionth
download was like 2% I think on the day
that happened and it was us and so I got
a call in Chicago I was in Chicago I got
a call from the woman who runs all of
developer relations from Apple and she's
like hey good morning you were the
billionth app downloaded yesterday we'd
like to you know tell the world about it
but I wanted to call you to make sure
that your servers are gonna be able to
handle it and I was like oh yeah let me
let me call you back
so I call Andy I'm like handy are we
gonna be able to do this he's like I
don't know and I said okay that sounds
like a yes so just we said yeah go for
it and and that then put us on the map
like that was the thing that got us
globally like everybody heard of well
promoting you or what happened is yeah I
mean Apple like did a marketing a little
effort marketing around it but then
later like after we joined YC that
summer they
they put us into an international TV
commercial this was the like there's an
app for it and then people might
remember and we were part of that and we
didn't really know we were gonna be a
part of it the way Apple works is
they're very secretive they say like
would you please sign this waiver that
says we can use your brand in various
things and I'm like okay sure
and yeah one day during YC are certain
we were looking at our graphs and our
servers just like like it like was a
factor of a thousand in ten minutes well
and we were like what's going on there
must be a bug and then our friends
started pinging us saying hey wait I
just saw you during Dancing with the
Stars and I'm like oh wow and that's the
point where our servers like totally
melted down everything broke and this is
the first moment where I realized the
value of the YC Network I sent an email
out to you know YC founders and I said
hey does anybody know how to I think we
were using a patch there's like an
Apache web server in our stack at the
time and I said does anybody like
there's anybody an expert at this they
came over to our office and just sat in
our desks and they said like step away
from the keyboards we'll fix it and they
just totally fix it for us and so that
was the first moment where I was like oh
YC is really valuable I didn't like I
remember when I was talking to Paul
Graham about how we should do this and
he said I won't be able to explain it a
priori why it's really valuable but I
guarantee you'll see that it's very
valuable and that was the first moment
where I was like yep he was right I'm
curious about how you got into I see
this so like on duty nobody before
housing to be like ya know we didn't
know anything about it honestly Jake and
I were in Business School we were trying
to like learn about tech because we like
everybody in business school you're
supposed to go get an internship for the
summer and so we were like oh where
should we get our internships so we were
like reading TechCrunch a buncha we like
kept seeing this thing called Y
Combinator I was like what is that and
it turns out we knew a couple people who
had gone through it already and so we
went and talked to those people I knew
savage who had done watt vision I think
was his first one and like I went and
talked to him and he's like yeah you
should totally do it and so we ended up
applying and got in the interview
process was fascinating to me as an
outsider in this world who was
interviewing you our interview was PG
Jessica Robert Morris and Trevor Trevor
yeah for them I can only imagine what
were their responses when you're like ok
so this is an AB
sherry consecration it was fascinating
we walked in and we sat down and
literally before I could open my mouth
Paul said give us your phone so we want
to try it and I was like okay so I hand
our phones over to him and they just
start playing around like RTM was like
I'm gonna try to hack it and break it
like let's all bump at the same time and
see if we can break it right and then
and I I do distinctly remember Jessica
being like so how do you guys know each
other like tell me about that and like
that was a moment where I was like oh
okay she's interested in understanding
like how the founders know each other
what our backgrounds are like what type
of people are we whereas like Trevor and
Robert were just like hacking away at
the tech right nerds there was a
fascinating moment and the the most
surprising sentence that was spoken in
our interview was at some point PG just
kind of like detached and like put his
head down and was kind of just thinking
and he said how does this become bigger
than Google and I was like dude are you
crazy but that just shows like how he
thinks that like you can take something
that seems so frivolous at the beginning
it turned into something potentially
that would be really big that was that's
so cool and so where did you establish a
metric early on during YC like what was
your goal before demo day we were really
anchored on how many people used it and
how many times they used it that's like
the the main thing that we were focused
on in hindsight that probably was not
the right thing to be focused on but I
think especially for us as total newbies
to this space we didn't know anything
better and so this was actually one of
the big learnings that we had at pump
that we we grew like crazy like it we
got up to 150 million downloads of our
app and I think at the peak we were at
like 10 million monthly active users so
it was like wow very big property
especially ten years ago on the internet
that was like really big but the the
thing we were looking at was like how
many people use it and how many bumps
were happening per day and per month and
what we weren't tracking as precisely as
we should have was do the people who use
it today like when do they keep using it
how frequently did I use it and what is
the retention curve so I remember what
we were raising money and all the VCS
would ask like what's your cohort
retention curve look like and I would be
like oh it's good and then I go and like
Google cohort retention curve like what
is that and I was trying to learn like
what
this metric that people keep talking
about and in hindsight now I realized
it's like the single most important
thing and with with bump the actual
dynamic was that our long-term cohort
retention was really good actually if
you measured it on a wide enough time
period basically people kept it on their
phone and they would definitely use it
at some point in the future the problem
was the frequency of use was very long
and so we thought that we were gonna be
able to build a business off of a large
user base using this product but if
you're a large user base uses your
product infrequently you have to figure
out a way to extract a lot of value each
time they use it
and for bump that the value was marginal
it was like yeah it's nice it's
convenient I could solve my problem in
another way and it's not that hard so
ultimately that was the thing that kind
of killed it as a business for us hmm
but surely you tried things right like
what you try to push into before you
ultimately decided to do something with
photos yeah we thought about a bunch of
ideas like should we just charge for the
app or should we have a freemium model
where there's certain feature set that
you would get if you would pay
we tried like in-app purchases for
different like stickers and things like
that we tested all these things as like
tiny 1% tests we tried two ads in the
product also as a little test and I bit
we basically concluded we could
basically get like maybe 1 million oh
sorry one dollar for every user of the
product per year on average and then we
realized like oh we've got 10 million
monthly active users like that's a nice
business but it's not a business that
you go raise huge amounts of VC funding
to go build so that that was the point I
think this was in like beginning of 2012
maybe where we realized oh hmm we need a
better plan because our plan all to that
point was just grow grow grow grow
Facebook did it
Twitter's doing it we'll just do it too
and it'll be great and I think we didn't
understand the fundamental differences
between our business and those
businesses what what made the product
grow like what made bump be so big it
100% word-of-mouth distribution so we
spent no money on customer acquisition
no money on marketing I used to tell the
story that the amount of money we ever
spent on marketing I think was like $42
and it was for me to buy a videotape to
put into a
borrowed camcorder and a black piece of
felt to put behind so I could make the
demo video for bump in my apartment was
it but yeah it was all word of mouth
people who got the app thought it was
cool enough that they wanted to be like
hey go stuff try it like I want to show
you this cool app I just downloaded and
what we thought was gonna be an
inhibitor to growth which is this
chicken and egg problem like I you can't
use it unless I have it actually turned
out to be the driving force behind our
distribution because it was like novel
and cool enough that people were willing
to like take that investment to say yeah
just download it all wait and you know
that worked and you thought about
pragmatic fate quite a bit you mentioned
that and wanted that talks to to Yui C
so we'll come to [ __ ] in a second but
but there's three different parts you
work in the last couple years and and
like what's your like when you think
about the word product market fit for
the width in terms of bump like what how
do you analyze that today it kind of
like after the fact yeah product market
fit I still it's a very subjective
concept I don't think you can really
measure it because you can have very
great product market fit with some
customer base but as you try to expand
your customer base you might find like
oh yeah there's not product market fit
for these other people over here and so
saying that like you've reached product
market fit it I think is really like
it's a staged question and ultimately
like if you want to be huge in a
consumer space you've got to get to a
large group of people and the question
is do you have product market fit for
that large group of people even with
Google photos today like my answer would
be we certainly have product market fit
for a large group of people in the world
but there's another group of people who
use our product that I wouldn't say is
product market fit necessarily there's a
whole lot more things that we need to
understand and build for that you know
when you get to like a billion or more
users there's the the next person who
joins your product like they're very
different than the first person who
joined your product and so you've got to
really understand that got it yes so
after after bump you guys tried another
product it's just so flock came it came
around tell us about that yeah so we
built bump to share the contact sharing
problem and people started using it for
that Apple eventually added an API to
access photos on the on the phone and we
lot we thought okay let's just add that
let's see what happens it's pretty cheap
to do so we added that feature and
people started using that and it
turned out that turned into the biggest
single use case of bump sharing photos
and so one day in I guess beginning of
2012 when you know I was looking at our
dashboards and I'm like I think it's not
gonna keep growing what are we gonna do
I thought back to the advice that I
heard PG give us back in YC which was
when you're stuck go talk to your users
they will always tell you what they want
so I said okay guys give me the list of
the top 100 users of bump in the world
I'm gonna like try to go have phone
calls with them so Jake and I that day
went into a conference room and just
tried to call as many of those people on
the phone as we could and we said hey
we're the founders about we just wanted
to hear like what you think of it why do
you use it that sort of thing and what
we heard was basically most of those
people said oh I don't use it for
contact sharing I use it to share photos
with my husband and we're like wait what
you can just email the photos why do you
do it and you know these people would
tell us well it's just easier and they
get the full resolution file and I don't
have to worry about attachments and
emails bouncing like it's just easy and
we thought oh and that then led us to
okay so there's clearly a problem in the
photo sharing space amongst your like
friends or family but the product we
built is like kind of the most hard
product to use to solve that problem
because both people have to download
this app you have to stop what you're
doing and like both decide okay we're
gonna do this bump thing now either
physically it's a physically touch it's
like when you're building product you
try to minimize friction of using your
product and with bump it was almost like
we've maximized the friction so we were
like okay let's try to build a product
that minimizes the friction rather than
maximizes it and so that led us to this
product called flock that we built and
launched it was really a a very
convenient turn of events where at the
same time that Jake and I were sitting
in that conference room roughly having
that learning or that insight our
engineering team was developing the bump
algorithm which was really like a
pattern matching early type of AI system
that would use a bunch of signals to
predict whether you bumped with another
phone because it was all server based
there's no right there's no again FC and
it was all kind of like a magic trick
but our engineers said hey Dave I can
tell you who's gonna bump with whom
tomorrow and I'm like
how can you do that and the answer was
they would go look at where and when
people took photos on their phone so
they look at the metadata of their
camera roll and they could say like I'm
pretty sure Gustaf's gonna bump with
Craig tomorrow there's an 80%
probability that they do and I'm like no
way and what they did is they figured
out that like today you two were at the
YC office and you took a photo and you
took a photo at the same time and
they're like probably they you're gonna
bump those photos to each other and so
that was the key insight on a tech side
that allowed us to kind of marry those
two insights and create this product
flock so flock looked at your Facebook
friends and figured out when you took a
photo at the same time as when your
other friend was there and then it
basically did a suggested sharing prompt
to you to say hey it looks like you
might want to share this photo and just
press this one button and we'll share
the photo to the other person and we
built that app we used it ourselves we
use it with our friends and family
before we launched and we realize like
wow this is really great like it just
makes my life so much easier I'm getting
all these photos from my friends that I
was never gonna get otherwise and then
we launched it and nobody downloaded it
and we were like aw shucks
this and what we didn't really
understand which we learned through this
experience was this is a Chris Dixon
blog post which is that like come for
the tool stay for the network idea which
is that the first users of your product
have to have some core utility that
makes it useful for them even when no
one else in the world has the product
and with flock it was like i download
flock and it says great go convince your
friends to download this app so that you
can get some value out of it and 99% of
people were like cool homescreen and
they never so that was the key insight
there and we learned was that if we
wanted to solve this like automated
photo sharing problem we had to upstream
ourselves and yet one stack want one
step higher in the stack and actually be
the camera roll and if we were the
camera roll then everybody's gonna be
using the product anyway and then all
this sharing stuff would actually work
and so that led us to the third product
that we built well what gives you that
insight though that you needed to go
upstream but basically none of our
friends were using it and we asked them
into life so just user conversation I
would like talk to it you know like a
lot of the YC Network I'd go talk to him
I'm like hey I see that like I looked in
our logs I see that
downloaded the app but you're not using
it like how come and people would say
you know and you have to interpret what
they say but they would say like oh you
know I none of my friends have it yet so
once they get it then it's gonna be
awesome caching and that led us to see
like okay but you're not you're not
driving your friend to get it
whereas in bump you were driving your
friend to get it what's the difference
and the difference was this novelty
factor of like it's this cool thing that
you want to show off for block the world
had moved a little bit there were a lot
of photo sharing apps people felt this
like burden to convince their friend
like hey I want you to download another
photo sharing app it'll be really cool
and there's something about the physical
morality the physical clumsiness that
people see there are some apps that use
or like pokemon go use run around the
street like holding up your phone like
people are gonna take notice but that's
not really the case with most apps you
just look at your phone and oh I have no
idea what he's doing the the physical
nature of bump I think made a big
difference I remember the first time I
saw someone in the wild like bump that
wasn't my friend yeah and it was like a
really visceral feeling I'm like wow
they just used bump okay so I think that
was a big part of it and this is kind of
a magical time a critical type of photo
sharing like 2012 Instagram was like a
year in could you until our head had
just yeah could you anticipate at the
time where photo sharing was going to go
like it's very easy in hindsight to
always say oh yeah of course I mean
billion two billion dollar thing but I
like to think that we intellectually
understood it but I don't think we did I
think we more emotionally understood it
or personally understood it and I think
we we really use this technique that pg
talks about which is if you want to come
up with great startup ideas just try to
live at the edge of the future like be
the the power user of whatever thing
you're interested in and then things
will just be obvious to you and you
won't even like intellectually
understand them you'll just be like this
is useful and cool I'm gonna go build it
I think that's what happened to us yeah
we were like in hindsight looking back
it's now obvious to me but like growing
up I was always the the person in my
family that would like organize the
photos and like make sure the photos
were taken I was the person who would
always ask my parents like hey can we do
a slideshow night and like you tell me
like who these people in these photos
were so looking backwards it's obvious
that I was interested in this space but
at the time we were all using iPhones
pretty
a lock and we were taking a bunch of
photos we were seeing these problems of
like oh my iPhone's almost full I better
um float it to my Mac and we were doing
the cable connection but normal people
were just like yeah my phone's getting
full I'm gonna delete some photos and we
were like oh that's unfortunate you
shouldn't have to do that and I think
that kind of led us from flock it made
us realize there were there was a whole
other set of problems when it comes to
photos that nobody was really solving
yet and we were personally experienced
them and so that combined with the
failure of flock and the success of it
for people who did get it made us
realize we should build this third
product so the third product we built
was this product we called photo roll it
was really like a better photo gallery
app if this was right on the heels of
when inbox launched I don't know if
people remember this yeah but it was
like a better email client and so we
were gonna try to pull an inbox and
build a better photo product and and
just you know distribute it on the app
store and people could download it
replace their default app with it and we
built a prototype of it like we I was
using it on my phone and it was really
great and it had flock built into it on
the side and so that made it so that
people could just download this better
photo gallery app and then all of a
sudden as their friends started to get
it it just started to light up for this
photo sharing behavior unfortunately we
have this great insight like kind of at
the end of our runway from our twenty
million dollars that we had raised and
we realized okay this photo product is a
winner if we can figure out a way to
like have a long runway and build it but
ooh we're gonna have to go raise a
Series C on bump to try to do it and
we're not we're not even raising that
money to go work on this one hundred and
fifty million user product that we've
got it was just a very like we looked at
it we said I wouldn't invest in that
okay let's talk my farm funders know
this but I mentioned that it also after
you guys raised from some of the
absolute top pcs in the world chocolate
out I went and so like how he feels like
from the outside like from the inside
like I just say everyone thinks that why
you must be the most successful company
ever oh I see how does that feel
yeah we were very fortunate we raised
from Sequoia for our series a or bridge
round before that was Ron Conway and
then our Series B was Marc Andreessen
entries in Horowitz so we had the cream
of the crop in terms of investors it was
it felt really great and I think
we were ignorant to to the truths of the
world about like were we actually gonna
be a really successful company or not we
didn't know and and honestly I don't
think any of the investors knew at the
beginning what we saw was mobile as this
huge wave that we all knew was gonna be
really big and bump was the most popular
app on mobile so like and it solves some
of these core problems that we all
believed would be real so I think that
was the investment thesis that's like
that was our kind of like investment
thesis for dropping out of business
school and doing this is it's working
Mobile's gonna be big we got to give it
a shot I think that was the same way
that how was the fundraising experience
like it was very easy like I feel I feel
guilty saying it but it was super easy
you know in YC I think we got to like
either I think it was either four or
eight million users during YC which at
the time was just unheard of so
everybody wanted to invest and we met
Sequoia folks and we thought oh they're
they're pretty good right and then we
raised that round and then I think it
was six months later mark emailed me and
he's like hey I want to invest I'm like
mark I just raised my series hey like
I've got two million dollars left like
what are you talking about and he said I
think it's gonna be big I want to invest
and so we took the meeting and I think
we delayed it like another six months
but then we raised seventeen million
from them and it was again on this
thesis that we don't know where this is
gonna go but it's gonna go somewhere
very interesting so let's just plow
ahead in hindsight I wish I had raised a
little bit less money in that series B
because it would have forced us to have
some of these existential questions or
discussions a little bit earlier like
because we had so much runway we could
just say like well we'll figure it out
and we just kind of kept going for maybe
an extra year in there so that question
comes up with funders a lot that I am
talking to so if they're doing really
well at fundraising and they're like
well there's more investors want to give
me another three million dollars now
should I take it with that extra
dilution and my advice typically well if
you have discipline and you can put half
of the money in a different Bank County
don't touch it for 12 or 18 months that
you should take it but most people
actually don't have that discipline
that's true yeah and investors want you
to use the money like yeah no investor
wants to say like oh yeah I've moved
some capital from my LP account into a
different bank account but it's just
gonna sit there don't worry it's earning
1% interest like nobody wants to hear
that
so it's very difficult to do that what I
would the advice I give entrepreneurs is
raise more money if you know how you're
gonna use that money today like if you
have no idea how you're gonna raise it
you're just like I some more money mom
you should only do that if you already
have a very proven business model and
there's risks that you want to mitigate
right like I'm an investor in Flex port
they just raise the big round and I
think I doubt he knows exactly how he's
gonna use that money today but he knows
like I've got a thing that's working
there's existential risks that I want to
mitigate and so you raise that round but
at the early stage yeah I I'm very
skeptical of raising money when you
don't know why you need it
hmm so in retrospect do you think you
could have like pulled it out of the
tailspin and turned a profitable product
out of all the work you put in oh I
think we totally could have made bump
profitable I don't I just did none of
the scale yeah like I don't think we
could have made it profitable at the
scale that you know a Sequoia or in an
injuries and Horowitz needs it to be
okay so how do we not raised VC funding
I think it would have been a great
business yeah we would have we would
have made a freemium model where like 1%
of users bought that for $1 or something
like that and it would have been great
right but then it's also tricky going
and thinking about raising Series C for
a product that also might not be
profitable at all right yeah so we
looked at photo role and we were like
people are gonna love this it's gonna be
big if we could get it to be like
distributed or part of an operating
system like either Apple or Google we
think it would be pretty big and but
then we were like and that would cost a
lot of money if we were gonna do it
because we wanted to store all the
photos in the cloud and so we like did
the math and we're like okay storing all
the photos of the world is going to be
expensive and so we kind of decided to
do this right you've got to do it in a
big environment where you can have very
long-term horizons and so when we were
getting acquired you we had a number of
options and with Google it really just
clicked in terms of like how we would
fit into the the mission of the company
like the mission of Google is to
organize the world's information and
make it universally accessible and
useful and for photos now Google photos
are our mission was store all your
photos be a home for your photos make
them as useful as possible to you and
then get them to the people that want
them which is like exactly mirroring the
Google mission so that that felt really
well really good
the DNA or the cultures of the companies
were very much aligned like we were at
bump we were kind of like nerdy quirky
people and we were like into physics and
into math and that sort of thing and at
Google we felt at home yeah compared to
you know when we would talk to Facebook
or talk to Apple the DNA fit just wasn't
quite as good I think so that was
another reason that what was their lead
you know the Android team it was her
photos team do you join it was a Picasa
back in the days right
so yeah Google has been on the photos
trajectory for a while beginning with
with Picasa there was that acquisition I
think it was in 2005 to that Picasa and
then Picasa turned into Picasa Web and
then when Google+ launched it got rolled
into Google+ and so we showed up in the
fall of 2013 and Google was full speed
ahead on Google+ and they were starting
to build more and more photo related
features into Google+ with the goal of
getting you to share them on the social
network we our conversation with Google
began with the Android team and it was
in the context of like the gallery app
on Android could be a lot better and
smarter and here's a here's an app that
could do it and so the acquisition was
really to take photo role and turn it
into something that would be useful at
the Google scale and it was really
convenient we joined Google and we like
started to ask around about who's
working on what and we actually were now
moved over as part of this photos team
inside of Google+ and I showed up and
I'm like hey I've got this idea that I
think is gonna work around building a
photo gallery app like a private photo
management tool that allows you to share
and have this cool like AI stuff in it
and I was kind of like but I don't have
any IAI like we're just here and we
showed up and we looked around and we're
like oh wow they've got like this huge
team working on face face recognition
face grouping technology they've got
this other huge team working on
understanding the content of images and
being able to search images they got
this other team around scale ibly
backing up photos at like a huge scale
and I just saw this and I'm like oh this
is it this is gonna be good it's a
perfect fit and and what I think we
brought to the table as photo roll was
this insight around like how do people
think about their photos what is the
right design of a product how do you
build these sorts of features
a way that would fit into their lives
really well and so the combination of
those two things turned into Google
photos and definition of actually
uploading every single photo for every
single yeah album is actually there
right now that's what you do yeah we do
yeah yeah we we upload a lot of photos
every day yeah well what was the insight
that led you to create I understand the
sharing between people the
facial-recognition that's awesome
searching is so cool what was the
insight that led you to start doing the
animations and stuff like that yeah so a
lot of that stuff is actually already
being done inside of Google Plus oh and
they did it to try to give you something
interesting that would be post worthy
that would make you want to post it on
G+ the the process that we took when we
when we were designing Google photos was
to use this technique that I like to use
a lot which is pretend that there's a
human being doing the thing that your
product is going to do and pretend that
human being like doesn't have to sleep
is really smart has access to all the
computing power and brain power in the
world what could that human being do for
you and so we were talking about this
this morning but for for photos I
thought okay if my co-founder Andy was
my photo assistant and all he did all
day long was like help me with my photos
what would he do and we just started
brainstorming like what were the things
he would do that would be useful to me
things were like make sure that he
backed up a copy of every photo so if I
lost my phone I didn't lose my photos
cool he would look at all the photos and
he would know who's important to me in
my life he'd know who's my mom who's my
dad who's my sister who's my girlfriend
and he would like write on the back of
each of those photos metaphorically like
this one contains mom and dad this one
contains Jenna and then we were like
well what else could he do and then I'd
say oh I kind of asked him to go learn
like Final Cut Pro and I'd want him to
make me like cool montage movies of my
life when there's something interesting
I'd want him to like remind me when it's
like the one-year anniversary or
something cool that happened in my life
or something meaningful I'd want him to
like go edit my photos if I have a photo
that's like too dark or messed up I'd
want him to edit it if I have photos
that are like blurry or crappie I'd want
him to suggest that I get rid of those
and so we just made this laundry list of
things that would actually be really
useful to me but no one was doing
because we didn't have that Andy doing
it for me and that was the insight that
kind of led
to how we designed google photos which
was it's your home for your photos but
then it's basically like this really
helpful assistant that would just do all
this other stuff for you and that that
persists to this day and it's working
very well that model what's your date
day today to look like today
when you've come into work at Google
like how does it like to to run one of
the 17 billion building the user apps in
the world right it's great it's very
diverse like how I spend my time is very
diverse I would say I'll answer it on a
monthly basis rather okay basis just
because every day is very different on a
monthly basis I think I spend you know a
quarter of my time maybe thinking about
the strategy aspects like where should
we take the team where should we take
the product what is changing about the
world or our user base that we need to
understand and kind of move in one
direction or another
maybe another quarter is like working
with our team and helping our team
whether that be like developing managers
on our team figuring out how to
structure the team which leaders should
we put in charge of which things that's
like another quarter another quarter
which is like probably my most
pleasurable quarter is like actually
working with people on our team directly
to think about what we should do with
the product like thinking about okay how
much should we change for our sharing
model like how can we make it better or
you know one that I'm working on right
now is this like photo assistant the
ability that we have like what's the
next step how do we like do something
more with that that's like another
quarter and then the last quarter is
like stuff that you've got to do if
you're running a team and it's you know
help people with their with feedback how
do they get better as a team how do they
get better as an individual kind of the
the stuff that you don't think about
when you're a start-up with ten people
but when you're a company with hundreds
of people you're like okay I need to
come up with a good system where we can
give feedback to people on our team we
can help develop them we can make them
better so this was the next thing I
wanted to talk to you about yeah like
how do you think about your work now
coming from you know basically three
people yeah to a small start-up so now a
very big team like obviously like the
management strategies are different how
you spend your time is different but
like how do you actually feel about it
it's very different people ask me this
question all that's
they're like what was it like like what
was the culture shock like going from a
startup to a big company and I think I
might be lucky but it doesn't feel like
that at all to me it feels like our
startup acquired a multi-hundred person
team it really does and it I think it
just says speaks volumes to the fact
that our DNA match with Google was
really good and that when we joined we
eventually were given the autonomy and
authority to actually like chart the
path for this product and that was a
rocky road but like eventually we got
there so yeah I think that's how it
feels to me and it's really it's a
luxury it feels great and and this is
actually after after kind of having that
insight at Google when I invest in
companies this is a question I
explicitly asked them is if you could go
acquire a big company with the purpose
of furthering your vision which big
company would you acquire and hearing
the answer that question help helps me
understand a their ambition and be how
do they think about where they want to
take this thing long term and so I often
asked this question they're like wait we
don't have any money we can't acquire a
company what are you talking about I'm
like no no it's a thought experiment
just yeah and I think it's really
fascinating to hear those answers so one
thing I'm curious about so I would argue
that Google focus is like one of the
magical AI experiences where like you
actually take a great product and you
add machine learning and AI and make it
magical and there are lots of startups
that come to IC and apply wood ideas
that relates to AI but how do you think
about like how would you advise them to
say I have this product and they have
this like machine learning capability
I'm adding to it like what are you
typically when you see those companies
what do you ask him I what do you advise
them yeah I think the thing that really
worked about Google photos is it was one
of the first examples of AI solving real
problems that people could resonate with
a lot of the AI stuff I see is does not
do that and you're like how does the AI
actually uniquely make this bet better
so in thinking about how you could apply
AI I kind of think about it in two
different vectors one factor is is there
a thing that human beings can do either
with skill or time or resources that
they don't do at scale today
but we could bring a computer in to do
that job that's kind of like what Google
photos that's our approach in many ways
and I think there's a lot of problems
that could be solved in the world that
today you could solve easily with a good
human being but you just don't have that
many good human beings at the right
price yeah all right so that's one
vector that I love to see and that one I
fully believe in the other vector is
problems that human beings cannot solve
today things like how do you optimize
the power usage of a data center like a
human being could never solve that
problems way to it's beyond our brains
that's the other vector where AI can do
really fascinating things and I think
that one is a lot harder to know a
priori whether it's going to work or not
and so those ones are riskier bets but
in many cases there are much bigger
payoffs if you can get it right so
that's how I think about it so my advice
to people who are like an AI startup is
tell me which of those two are you like
are you trying to solve this unsolvable
human problem are you just trying to
scale a very solvable human problem to a
whole lot of people or at a much cheaper
price and when you're doing that what
are the things you're gonna go build
like what is the solution that you're
gonna try to show to your users and if
your answer is something that the
solution even though the AI tech is
super cool if the solution is like yeah
that's nice but right whatever then it's
not gonna work right so and so it seems
like this this attention to the user and
attention to product is like a core
belief of yours it's not about the
technology right and this was a thing
that I noticed at Google when I joined
and I think since that period like in
the five years that have passed Google
has really made a transformation to
focus much more on the user but at the
time there was still a lot of like cool
tech being developed and everybody at
Google is a technologist and they're
like is is really cool but they're they
weren't asking the question as much
about well how does it solve a user
problem and is it really a core user
problem that we should solve and so I
think you know as sundar has taken over
at Google he's really tried to focus the
company on the user and how can we be
helpful to users and I think that has
just really played out in the form of
Google photos is it different to talking
to users at scale when you bill users
versus when you're going to startup how
is the different yeah I've got a tab
open in my Chrome browser for each of
our platforms for iOS Android and web
that is the raw stream of feedback that
you can send
in the app and like every day we get
like thousands of reports and so I can't
even read them all anymore whereas at
the startup I can read every single
email in fact at bump until I think
through the through the acquisition I
was the only customer support person
like I wrote back to every single email
and I blocked like an hour or an hour
and a half every day doing it and it was
it was kind of one of these things that
like can't scale and it was probably a
bad use of my time at some point but it
taught me that like you listen to people
and generally they will tell you what
you should do you just need to
understand how to interpret what they're
saying it's a great practice I think
that's something we should recommend all
early startup to do because it gives you
just the recollection connection with
the users
yeah one thing we did at bomp which I
really enjoyed is we would take our team
and go to bars and and do user testing
and like talk to people and one reason
we did it at bars is that people are
like in a more social environment so
like bumping was something that you
would actually do there whereas like
managing your photos maybe it's harder
to find the moment when people are in
that in that mode but the other thing is
when people have a couple drinks they
like actually tell you what they think
whereas when you bring someone into a
lab and like set them down behind the
mirrored glass they know they're being
studied and so they behave differently
and so this is a thing that I think is
challenging at scale is how do you how
do you do that you can't just like tell
google employees like yeah go to bars
and ask people what they think it's not
gonna work so you know I would say it's
an area that that in general could
probably be improved is how do you
create these learnings in this empathy
with users at scale for a team that's
large and for a user base that's very
large right I mean so do you have like a
system that's just parsing the text and
looking for key words do ya we we have
some AI systems that like read the
feedback try to cluster it into
different clusters and then some humans
look at that and try to understand if
there's interesting insights we've got a
user research team that goes out into
the world and asks people we do trips
like a couple summers ago I spent two
weeks in India just living in India
trying to understand what about Indian
people is different than what is about
you know people in Mountain View yeah
there's a lot of differences so we try
to do stuff like that we bring people
into our office also but again like that
has its own challenges in terms of
knowing that you're being tested but
yeah we try to do as much of this as
possible and I think I honestly I put a
lot of weight in
what you what what intuition you can
build by just talking to your users I
think we overlook the fact that we've
got the best computing platform that has
ever been built and it's our brains and
we can use it to give it inputs and then
let it do its magic and pattern match
and then output our intuition and I
think that that is really what your gut
is and it really is like a sophisticated
machine learning system that we should
actually utilize so I'm a big believer
in building what you think is right yeah
absolutely so a question from Twitter
related to products lamby day acha acha
mola Fay hopefully I got that right asks
what did David focus on too much that he
thinks was a mistake now when you are a
rookie product leave oh great question
what did we focus on too much what one
thing it bumped that we focused on a lot
was like how good the system was like
how performant was it measuring you know
we obsessed over like microseconds here
in milliseconds there and I I love that
culture and it's a culture that we try
to really push on Google photos as well
but I think if you focus on that a
little too much early on you might be
missing the much bigger picture which is
like yeah even if you made it like super
awesome people aren't gonna care and I
think that that is an insight that is
hard to really have when you're in the
moment in the details your system is
running and you're like crap it's like
it's really slow right now all the users
are complaining it's so easy to just be
like great let's go fix that and it's
very hard to pull back and say maybe
that's not the problem we should be
fixing maybe there's some other problem
that we need to understand and I think
that is the trap that a lot of companies
fall into this is the this is the Sam
Altman it's like one of my favorite
quotes from Sam is I think it's like he
says the the meta problem that kills
most startups is working on the wrong
thing it's not like screwing up whatever
you're working on it's not your
competitors is that you were just
focused on the wrong thing and I think
that in in the product world it's this
trap that you can fall in which is like
oh this is not as good as it could be we
should make it better where even if you
made it perfect it doesn't matter
and actually you needed to work on this
other thing so that's probably my number
one hmm
advice yeah and so now that you're
working on it at large scale that's like
these product inside
what degree of buy-in do you have to
feel before you ship it out to a billion
people like when you're testing some new
thing yeah great question we do a number
of things to get confidence in some
product that we're gonna build or some
feature that we're gonna build the first
thing we do is use it ourselves okay and
if if we think it's not working then
it's very likely it's not going to work
in the market and and this is a luxury
that we have because we build Google
photos it's a product that we're
building for ourselves and for a lot of
other people who are not like us but we
are at least somewhat representative of
the user base compared to you know if we
were building a product for like you
know kids that are under 8 years old
like I personally don't have a ton of
intuition about that and I wouldn't be
able to know innately whether this is
gonna work or not so that's a whole lot
more challenging problem and I have so
much respect for people who can solve
problems that are where they are not the
user for us we are the user so the first
step is do we like it and often you know
I challenge our team where we've we've
like done experiments we've run stuff we
we were like about to launch something
and I just asked the team I'm like what
do you guys think about it do you like
it do use it like what's your most
annoying part of this product and often
they're like well I'm not the I'm not
the target user but like this is kind of
annoying to me and I'm like we should
get that right like come on so that's
that's number one number two is we we do
a bunch of testing with users before we
actually launch even in an experiment we
like make prototypes we bring it out to
people and you can learn a lot of
usability things like whether the actual
flows will work but you can't really
test do they care by doing those sorts
of tests we also do experiments we roll
things out to 1% we've got like a I
won't talk about it but we've got a
pretty big product in experiment right
now that we're excited about and we're
watching how people are using it we're
trying to keep it on the download and
that's another thing that we do and we
learn a lot from that and I think the
combination of all these things give us
gives us confidence that yep this is a
thing that we at least have high enough
confidence that we should roll it out
and see what happens hmm yeah so and
laminae akumal alpha is asking you did
you make any early mistakes when you
joined Google so like like as frankly
like what kind of is
new large organizations - you like what
my mistakes what you're doing bosses
would certainly say yes I think let's
see there are two problems and they're
wrapped together the the the meta
problem that I made met a mistake I made
was I really believed in this vision for
what we could build in the photo space
so much that like I was just determined
to solve it and I think the skill that I
needed to develop inside of a big
company which is very different than
what I had at at the startup was I now
had like three or four bosses above me
that I needed to convince and at the
startup I just had to like have a board
meeting and say hey Mark I'm gonna do
this and he's like cool do it whereas
here it was like hey I gotta convince
this person and then I've got to use
their support to garner support from
this other group of people and then I've
got to take that and create support from
the CEO right and it it's a very
different process and I was not very
adept at doing that and I just kind of I
used the modality of being the startup
founder and just saying like we need to
do this come on everybody let's go and
I'm gonna convince you and whereas at
Google I needed to be much more delicate
and I don't think I did a great job of
that one of the sub components of that
was how can you do that at a big company
and I have learned now is you can really
get a lot of support at the grassroots
level so what when I ran into these
problems going up the stack at Google I
kind of retrenched and said great let me
go talk to the people on the ground
actually talking to customers actually
building the product as opposed to the
people managing big teams doing it and
when I would go talk to those people a
lot of them said like oh yeah I get I
get it let's do it this makes a lot of
sense and by building some support there
we could then go in mass to the the
leader and say hey we all think it's
right here's all the perspectives here's
all the diverse opinions this is what we
think we should do and that is a much
better sell at a company especially if
you can have evidence in the market in
some way that like this this stuff is
working this other stuff is not working
let's look at it objectively and decide
what we should do in five or ten years
do you see yourself working for a large
company or startup that's a great
question
I love startups I love the
the rawness of startups the purity their
like every problem you face is like
there's no layers of abstraction you're
just in it and you're seeing the true
problem I love that it's a thing I try
to keep doing at Google the challenge I
guess it was when I look at like what I
could go startnext or what whether I
want to join a start-up or start any
startup
I kind of have have the luxury of
thinking about it in two dimensions one
is what reach will I have how many
people in the world can I affect with
this thing I want to build and the other
dimension is to what degree can I affect
their lives in a positive way and
looking at Google photos it's like we
have a path to affect billions of users
like the majority of people on the
planet we have a path to get there
that's pretty amazing
not many products can do that and then
on the importance or depth of the of the
experience I believe there's not a lot
of things more valuable to you than the
record of your life your your memories
right maybe the only things on top of
that are like being alive like your
health and maybe connections in the
moment to the people around you like
otherwise it's one of the most essential
parts of the human experience so I look
at that and I'm like I think this is
like probably the most impactful thing I
can be doing right now I actually give
that advice when I when the companies
ask me hey I got this position offer
from this large company I always try to
put like all the financial stuff aside
and so like everything else aside and
the the main question to me is always
can you execute any vision towards a
much larger audience in a better way
inside this company or not and if you
really believe that being part of this
other large company is the way for you
to get to your users and execute a
vision then that is the most important
question to answer yeah yeah and a
corollary is if you don't have that
alignment and you do go to that company
it's going to be a disaster yeah
basically most acquisitions don't turn
out well and it's fascinating you make
this big decision for your company that
we're gonna go get acquired by blank but
then if you look at like how many
minutes or hours did I spend with the
people I will be spending my entire work
life with it's usually really really
small like laughably small and most of
the discussions are on the financial
exam it's not actually about sort of
like the product outcome that should be
where most
out of the challenges I faced when I got
to Google were misalignments of vision
around what Google should do in the
photo space and it I wish we had had
those conversations beforehand the
problem is the conversations need to be
with these like senior level people at
Google and they don't have time to spend
like an entire weekend like spitballing
with me about some some random startup
entrepreneur like the future of what we
should do might or might not getting
quite right so it's it's this like
asymmetric problem and now that I'm on
the other side at Google like I try to
empathize with my former self yeah and
like you know we've done acquisitions
that photos and I try to just like spend
a lot of time with people make sure that
we're aligned on like what we want to
build because inevitably when you join
something's going to change and you're
gonna like have to tweak your plan in
some way and if you don't have that
fundamental alignment it's gonna be a
disaster
hmm so that's a thing I think is really
important you said something really
interesting about humans and their
attachment to photos of so I wanted to
kind of touch on this at some point yeah
so have you learned any kind of larger
truths about humanity by paying
attention to all of this stuff all the
time for years probably I don't know if
I'm great at articulating them let's see
yeah I think one probably the number one
truth I've I've seen is the power of
nostalgia I think we all feel it and we
all know that feeling but seeing it from
the perspective that I get to see it
it's one of the most powerful things in
the human experience I think and and
we've tapped into it in a variety of
little ways but I think there's a much
larger thing that we're still trying to
go learn and figure out but yeah I think
we each think about important moments in
our lives and they could be important
from like a grandiose perspective or
just like little moments in our lives
that stick with us and usually in that
moment there's like an image that you
have in your brain or like a song that
you associate with that moment or like a
smell there's something that like
triggers you and people love thinking
about the past it's just an innate thing
I think it's an evolutionary thing that
those of us who had that trait are
better at understanding where we've been
and better at like surviving in the
future so I think it is baked into us as
humans but it
is a really powerful phenomenon have you
mM everything in Fast and Slow wait
talks about so like how important for
the graphic memories are for happiness
yeah I haven't I totally believe it
one of our goals with Google photos is
to basically give everyone a
photographic memory the challenge is our
brains aren't act like most of us at
least don't have this like perfectly
linear evenly distributed photographic
memory the way our brains work is we
pick important moments and really like
write a lot to the disk during those
moments and then we kind of don't don't
worry about the rest and so one of the
challenges we have with Google photos is
we now have all the photos that you've
taken in your life how do we decide
which ones are the important ones that
we should like really focus on and try
to help you relive and engage with which
ones are like not important even though
they may seem important to our
algorithms and then on the other side
which ones are like not memories that
you want to re-engage with and this is a
big challenge and it's it's a very
difficult problem but we all have
moments in our lives or people in our
lives that were part of our life before
and it was an experience we had but
going forward it's not a thing that we
want to dwell on yeah and that's a
really difficult challenge and I'm like
I would say we're getting it okay but
not great and I want to that's an area I
want to improve yeah so I've one final
question as a product lead I was we had
similar role a a B & B I spent a lot of
time looking at other products and new
products
what are you top like other new apps the
European iPhoto space all right in
general like actually just just you feel
now like these are important to me yeah
consumer products yeah or just apps
generally yeah well in terms of like
categories that I see that I'm
interested in spanning like everything
one category that I think is fascinating
is basically taking like mundane systems
that humans have created and replacing
them with smart technology so flex port
is one example of that I just invested
last YC badge in this company Canary
technologies building software for
hotels like seems so mundane and like
who cares about that but it's a big
problem there's a lot of people go to
hotels and we need to make the
experiences better and one way to do it
is to make the software better so that's
like one category that I'm very
interested in another category that I'm
interested in is taking things that we
all take for granted like eating food
or having healthcare and applying some
of these technologies or things to make
those things better so one I just
invested in also in the last batch is
Seattle food tech they're making a
meatless chicken nugget
I just ate them the other day the newest
version of it and they're delicious and
it's like obvious to me that oh yeah
we're gonna this will be a thing some
form of this will be a thing
so applying technology to these like
very mundane physical parts of our lives
is another category that's interesting
on the consumer social yada-yada side
it's really tough like you I see lots of
cool stuff where I'm like there's
something cool in there but this thing's
gonna fail and I see I think that all
the time and I try to invest in them
because some fraction of them will
become really cool different different
world today movie we were like oh it
definitely is seven years ago
yeah it's we've like developers have
gone and like figured out all the
obvious wins already in the consumer
space and the ones that emerge are the
ones that seem like totally off off the
cut like who would have known ten years
ago that snapchat would have been like a
popular thing or that the stories format
would have been a popular thing it's
very hard to predict until you build it
and see it and then you're like oh yeah
that's no well let alone lip syncing
product because you know one thing on
the consumer side that I've come to
understand is there is a difference
between something that is really popular
for a while and something that is a
durable essential human need through the
Instagram phase given where I am in
photos like I got to see all the like
Instagram competitors where they have
like some new cool format right it like
turns your photos into art or it makes
this part of the photo move or it's this
cool looping effect and all of them have
the thesis like we're gonna take this
and turn it into Instagram and I my
feedback was always like but Instagram
already exists so you're not solving a
durable human need look at the timing or
what's the specific thing that they did
that made them succeed I think had those
things happened before Instagram
happened they could have pulled the same
thing off I mean Instagram pulled the
same playbook right yes yeah we let you
filter your photos they look slightly
different and but then they were able to
translate that into a network that was
durable and a human need that was
durable which is I want to interact with
other
people mm-hmm basically like that's
basically what Instagram is and so I
when I look at consumer stuff I try to
understand what is the fundamental human
need that your product is either scaling
across time and space or changing or
amping up in some critical dimension and
if I don't see that then I'm much more
skeptical right so that's it's kind of
my rubric for consumer stuff is tell me
the thing that humans already do today
in a limited not as great way that you
are going to somehow amplify times 10 or
times 100 that's what Facebook was
that's what Twitter is that's what
snapchat is all these things are exactly
that playbook executed really well right
on all right thanks so much for coming
in thank you so much yes great
you